so in this video we're going to talk
about the thyroid gland there are so
many people that are walking around with
a thyroid problem but its secondary to
something else in fact when they take
the thyroid medication they don't really
feel any better or they don't lose the
weight so the problem is associating
what's really underneath the thyroid
problem you know when you go to a doctor
they'll do a blood test and they may or
may not find anything they might not
look deep enough or even if they do find
it they'll put you on medication but you
don't always see changes so let's talk
about all the other possibilities of of
the actual cause of a thyroid problem
from my experience working with a lot of
doctors in the field most thyroid
conditions are not primary they're not
just the primary thyroid problem unless
you've been exposed to radiation then
the thyroid is located in the base of
the neck right here about two and a half
inches wide and the gland controls
metabolism if there's a problem with the
thyroid and it's a low thyroid nearly a
hundred enzymes inside your cells will
be blocked that's why you have problems
with protein you won't be able to absorb
the proteins in the body to make hair so
your hair dries out it's there you start
losing your hair you get vertical ridges
on your nails you have a loose skin
right here and right here you gain
weight all over not in any one location
you get cold feet
you have to wear socks to bed at night
you have problems with depression you
are tired despite how many hours of
sleep that you get decreased libido
digestive problems constipation you
crave carbs especially breads pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes now you could also have an
adrenal body type and have similar
symptoms but what you're going to look
at is what what are the most associated
characteristics with that body type and
then you would tend to you know deal
with that now in no way am i diagnosing
you or telling you to diagnose your your
own condition that's my disclaimer
because you get with your doctor if you
want to diagnose hypothyroidism I'm just
giving information to understand the
Associated symptoms
of the thyroid in relationship to other
causes okay so number one the liver
converts the thyroid hormones so in
other words if you look at the the t3
and t4 the number on that T or t3 or t4
represents the number of iodine
molecules that are on that hormone t4 is
really an inactive thyroid hormone and
it's activated through the liver to
become t3 so in your liver you have
certain enzymes to strip off one of the
iodine molecules to make it t3 to make
t3 the active form of thyroid hormone so
in other words eighty percent of the
thyroid function occurs through your
liver without a liver you cannot convert
and make your thyroid work okay so
that's one thing you know so if your
liver is damaged chances are you could
that could be the source of your thyroid
problem if you have constipation that
backs up the liver that could be a cause
of your thyroid problem if you have a
sluggish gallbladder or no gallbladder
that could be a source of your thyroid
problem because you're not able to
convert these hormones correctly and
just so you know if you don't have
enough bile which comes from a lot of
adrenal stress and you don't have that
that that substance called bile which
helps you break down fats for one reason
or another you won't be able to
concentrate the iodine to to make this
thyroid thing work to so many times you
might have a good liver but just not
enough bile production and that alone
could influence the thyroid okay so
those are some common causes it could be
your diets deficient iodine because the
soils are really really poor or maybe
you're allergic to iodine or maybe
you're allergic to shellfish which has
iodine okay those are possibilities the
other possibility is high levels of
estrogen okay that's another common
cause why do I know that because many
times females right after the
agency they develop a thyroid condition
because the spike of estrogen or women
that have thyroid problems usually have
high heavy high levels of estrogen
coming from heavy periods or having
crampy periods or painful periods
estrogen dominance will block the
thyroid because estrogen competes for
the thyroid receptors so it blocks the
receptors so too much estrogen can also
be the source of a primer of a thermal
problem okay so estrogen being the
primary cause the thyroid problem being
the symptom of high estrogen so these
are all things you want to look at
estrogen also condemned is the liver and
stopped the conversion from t4 to t3
estrogen can also concentrate the bile
to block the conversion from t4 to t3 so
you can see there's many many different
causes of thyroid problem so now the
question is how do we break it down how
do we find out what it is my way is
always like this I would like to ask a
question out of all these possibilities
which one would would make the most
sense which one would actually help
everything going on here and from my
experience it's um
it's usually a gallbladder bile problem
because once you have enough bile you
start to lubricate the colon so it gets
rid of constipation it allows the
conversion from t4 to t3 it helps the
digestion it takes the pressure off the
liver it allows the estrogen to flood
through the liver much better so you see
if you approach it from that viewpoint
by fixing one thing does it fix
everything at the same time because
these things are not individual problems
are all connected the principle that's
very true is that the underlying real
cause of any of these problems is
usually very obvious once you figure it
out it's nothing abstract nothing very
mysterious so that's what you want to
look for or let's say you say that we're
did this problem start right after a
pregnancy well we know then it's high
estrogen levels okay so anyway that kind
of gives you a deeper understanding of
thyroid conditions and what maybe you
should start
looking at in helping yourself with the
thyroid body type